تستضيف بريطانيا اليوم اجتماع لوزراء
العدل من نحو 40 دوله يناقش جرائم الحرب
المحتمله في اوكرانيا بعد صدور مذكره
توقيف ضد الرئيس الروسي من المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه وتعتزم الدول الاعلان عن
تعبئه موارد اضافيه لدعم تحقيق المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه حول جرائم الحرب
المزعومه في اوكرانيا وتنظم بريطانيا
وهولندا هذا الاجتماع بشكل مشترك وقد قال
وزير العدل البريطاني
يدافع عن قضيه محاسبه مجرمي الحرب على
الفضائع المرتكبه في اوكرانيا خلال ما
وصفه بالغزو الجائر وغير المبرر وغير
القانوني اما نظيرته الهولنديه فقالت ان
الاوكرانيين يستحقون الدعم لتحقيق العداله
ينضم الينا من امام لانكسر هاوس في لندن
مراسل الجزيره محمد مدهون اهلا بك معنا
اذا جهود لمحاسبه روسيا وتمويل تحقيق
الجنائيه الدوليه ضعنا في صوره انطلاق
اجتماع الدعم الذي يقوده الان المسؤولون
الاوروبيون
عبد السلام وصلت الوفود جميعها تقريبا
وبانتظار كلمات افتتاحيه من نائب رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني وزير العدل الدومين
كراب لحشد الدعم وتعبئه الموارد الماليه
والعمليه للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه لتحقيق
المحاسبه والعداله محاسبه مرتكبي جرائم
حرب وجرائم ضد الانسانيه محتمله في
اوكرانيا وعداله لضحاياهم وحمايه للشهود
على كل هذه الجرائم المفترضه حقيقه هذا
الموعد مثالي لهذا الاجتماع وهو ياتي بعد
ايام قليله فقط من اصدار مذكره توقيف بحق
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ومفاوضه
حقوق الاطفال الروسيه وكذلك بالتزامن مع
هذه الزياره للرئيس الصيني الى موسكو يريد
المجتمعون هنا ان يظهروا الرئيس الروسي
بوتين في مظهر المنبوذ المشتبه في ارتكابه
جرائم حرب الشخص الذي تلاحقه الان اجهزه
انفاذ القانون في الدول الموقعه على ميثاق
روما المؤسس للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
ويريدون ان ينقلوا هذه الخطوه من بعدها
الرمزي الى جانب عملي ان يظهروا اراده
سياسيه لاننا نعلم جميعا ان مذكره التوقيف
هذه ملزمه للدول لكن الدول لن تكون
بالضروره ملتزمه بها على الاقل هناك 40
دوله ارسلت ممثليها الى هذا الاجتماع
المجد والمسبقا بالمناسبه لم ياتي عقب
اصدار مذكره التوقيف انما كان مجددا في
هذا التوقيت ومخططا له منذ شهر يناير
الماضي هؤلاء يريدون القول انهم ينسقون
مواقفهم مع بعضهم البعض انهم ماضون في دعم
هذه المحكمه بالموارد الماليه والعمليه
بريطانيا قبل هذا الاجتماع اعلنت انها
ستمول المحكمه بنحو 400 الف جنيه استرليني
اضافيه ليصير دعمها المالي عند نح مليون
جنيه استرليني خلال الاشهر القليله
الماضيه وهذا ما كان قد طالب به المدعي
العام للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه كريم خان
الذي قال ان محكمته بحاجه الى مثل هذه
الموارد كي تستطيع القيام بعملها ولكن
الموارد ليست ماليه فقط ايضا هناك موارد
عمليه متعلقه بالتدريب المحققين بجمع
المعلومات والادله من قبل كل الدول
الاطراف وايجاد نوع من التنسيق التنسيق
والوحده هما الكلمتان المفتاحيتان اللتان
سمعناهما سمعناها من سمعناهما من معظم من
تحدثنا اليهم من وزراء في هذا المؤتمر
اليوم محمد المدهو مراسل الجزيره من لندن
شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه الاضاحات